yeah nothing ever good happens after 48
hours in vegas that's pretty much
all you really need in that and uh yeah
i used to go with a group of people who
wouldn't even get hotel rooms you would
just go
and do 48 straight hours and get back on
the plane and go back
so it's uh yeah it's that kind of town
how much time did you have to spend in
vegas
when you were doing the work like
researching for the story and
yeah so for bringing on the house i
spent about six months going back and
forth with the mit blackjack team
learning how they did it you know
carrying money on my body
watching them in action um and then to
write the book i actually
wrote it in vegas staying in a different
hotel room every night
so it was actually i wrote the book in
about 16 days
um so it was a very quick book but i
wrote it you know
i stayed everywhere i stayed you know
the worst hotels and the best hotels
because i wanted to get the feel of what
it's like to sort of
be a part of the card counting team so
then when we made the movie
um we shot for over a month maybe two
months in vegas
so i was on set for that as well so i
spent a fair amount of time in vegas
um and over the years i'm always there
four or five times a year i would say
um you know back pre pandemic
uh speaking gigs and and and that sort
of thing brings me to vegas a lot
but back when i was writing that book i
would say i spent a lot of time in vegas
yeah
so what did you contribute during the
filming of the movie
and what what do they like ask from you
creatively yeah so the author of the
book is like the lowest man on the totem
pole they don't even really want you
there
you're like they tell you to go hang out
at the bar basically
um i've always said a producer's
favorite author is a dead author
because you give them the book and then
they can go make the movie but 21 was
actually a really
fun movie to be a part of because it was
a whole all young
cast everybody involved was really young
it was kate bosworth and uh
jim sturgis who was amazing and um uh
aaron yu
um and uh you know became very concerned
that josh dad
who went on to play olaf and was just
this incredible actor
um and so they were all like hanging out
we shot for a couple months in boston so
they were all just hanging out in my
apartment
and we were playing video games going
out to bars and then we were in vegas
and we were hitting casinos
with a whole movie crew and card
counters
so it was this kind of wild traveling
circus where the security didn't
want the card counters near the
blackjack tables
but the actors they did want at the
blackjack table so we were kind of
mixing in
card counting and actors and it was just
really fun i i would say
in terms of what i contributed you know
once they've got a script and a director
the author contributes very very little
um you're basically hanging out until
we ended up getting some of us kicked
off the set because uh
the actors were getting too drunk with
the car counters but uh but it was uh
you know in the end i had a i had a
blast it was robert luke
was the director who had done legally
blonde um so everything looks beautiful
it's one of those movies
you can watch 21 just for sort of it
just feels like you're in vegas it's
it's
i think it's a very good movie it's not
rounders it's a very different movie
you know people who love cards
understand what rounders is and
understand what 21 is and there's a
c between those two movies but 21 is
that movie you watch
on the plane on your way to vegas for
the first time um and i think it's kind
of perfect for that
yeah it's a it is an amazing movie i
think the first time i saw it i was
it's probably close to 10 years ago
right when did it come out 2010
something like that
i think no it was 2007 i believe yeah
okay longer yeah
and so what about the social network
yeah how how did that come about and who
did you originally meet that introduced
you that story i believe somebody
emailed you out of the blue
yeah yeah so it was basically 21 was
about to have its premiere
um and i at two in the morning i got a
random email from a harvard senior
and he said my best friend founded
facebook and no one's ever heard of
him and you know i'd heard of mark
zuckerberg and never heard of anyone
else and this was you gotta remember
2007 around that period so
uh facebook was not a big thing it was
it was little it was you know college
kids it was a little bigger than that
but not everyone was on facebook um yeah
it was my space
yeah my space was bigger you know
friendster was still
kicking i think um i i went out for a
drink and walked eduardo um
and eduardo severin at that point had
never spoken to anyone
no one had ever met eduardo no one had
ever heard of eduardo
his name had been taken off the masthead
um
and he started the conversation by
saying mark zuckerberg me
um and so at that point i was a
journalist so i said tell me more
and he proceeded to tell me this great
story about you know him and mark
meaning in this underground
jewish fraternity and how you know mark
had almost gotten kicked out of school
for making that website where you could
vote on
who the hottest girl at harvard was and
and then he met the winklevoss twins and
uh and it was just incredible story i
mean everyone knows the story but
it was this wild never heard before
story um
you know and and i was blown away and so
i basically
hung out with eduardo for a few months
he talked to me and talked to me and
talked to me
it turns out and i found out much later
that he was attempting to use me
it was this machiavellian idea that he
could talk to me for a little while
and then scare facebook into settling
with him he was in the midst of this
massive lawsuit
suing facebook uh demanding you know to
get his percentage for having co-founded
it
but i didn't know this at the time i
thought this was a great book idea
so i wrote a 14-page book proposal and i
sent the book proposal to my agent and
it leaked online
it was actually gawker you remember the
awkward website
yeah they published my entire book
proposal which i'd never seen them do
before
and everything exploded at once um that
day
facebook settled with eduardo for five
billion dollars
um and if you look at the settlement
agreement it says you may never speak to
ben mesrick again
because they were trying to stop this
from happening they thought that they
could stop him from talking to me and
there wouldn't be a book and there
wouldn't be a movie
so eduardo cut off all contact with me
he got a legal restraining order and
sent it to me
he broke up with his girlfriend because
he was dating my wife's best friend at
the time
and then he moved to singapore never to
be heard from again
so i've never spoken eduardo since then
i ended up getting him five
billion dollars and he never even called
to send me a little gift basket
maybe maybe a couple hundred million
dollars i don't know he never
he never reached out again which i
understand because he had
you know he had to run away from me
based on the settlement agreement
um that same day aaron sorkin saw it
online
and said i want to write this as my next
movie um and david fincher saw it online
and said i want to direct this
as my next movie david fincher he did
fight club
right fight club seven seven uh
zodiac so many incredible movies uh
fight club really was my favorite
you know of his at the time but really
brilliant director and aaron sorkin of
course
um had done the west wing but had
written so many
incredible movies um and it's just one
of the greatest writers i think around
and and the two of them reached out to
and said i want to make this and
which was great yeah i had written the
book though
so it was one of these things where
you're like you know i sold the book
to these people and then locked myself
in a hotel room and just started writing
so they were reaching out to you just
based off the 14-page scenario so
all of my projects have been sold on 14
page treatments all of them
um you know there's a magic art to
writing these things these treatments
and in a lot of ways they're an easier
thing to sell than a full book
um but anyways yeah they came running
into boston and i sat in a hotel room
and i was handing chapters to sorkin as
i went and
when i finished the book i wrote the
book in about 12 weeks i would say
um and then he wrote the screenplay in
the next three four weeks and it was it
was brilliant i mean the guy is a genius
and uh and the movie was made within a
year which was incredible i mean you
never that never happens
and and uh so it was just this kind of
crazy wild
experience um so yeah it was just a
lucky random email
um reaching out to me and it was just
one of those moments um
and then the movie you know was was an
incredible hit
through it i became close to the
winklevoss twins um
and they were actually my main one of my
real
major sources for the movie in that when
i
when eduardo came to me the first people
i reached out to were the winklevoss
twins i just found them on facebook
and i wrote a message saying hey you
know i want to talk to you guys
and we we became close and they started
handing me you know
interesting things and and and all the
legal stuff which we were able to then
build into
into the social network so that's how i
got to know the winklevoss twins i got
to know sean parker as well
sean became a really big source sean was
trying to broker
an interview between me and mark
zuckerberg mark was not happy i was
writing his book he was very unhappy
um he knew that eduardo was involved he
knew the winklevoss twins were involved
he did not want that story being told he
wanted to tell his own story
um and so he kept turning me down kept
turning me down
sean and i would hang out and sean would
send him questions that i wrote and then
mark would refuse to answer them and
it was kind of this back and forth for
for a good year
um and in the end i ended up having to
write it without mark's input
um but um but yeah i had sean i had the
winklevoss twins
i had eduardo and i had uh so you know i
feel like it's a very true telling
from all these points of view other than
marx um mark would tell a very different
story
um but uh but i think that it's a pretty
accurate story
so